I wonder about these blood labs as I don't recall you mentioning them, and I hadn't even heard of most of them.
IL-1, IL-6, IL-8, and serioplasm for inflammation.
Veg F-T-F-G-B, I think it's T-G-B-F beta. F-G-B-I-G-F-1, HER2, and copper for progression or bats.
I know some functional medicine docs have been running D-diverse, and it's COVID for cardiovascular health.
Is that useful for cancer, too?
So, these markers are all inflammatory markers.
IL-1, IL-6, IL-8.
There's a bunch of different inflammatory cycle, what are called cytokines that start with IL.
Serioplasm is your main carrier for copper in your body.
Veg F is vascular endothelial growth factor.
These are chemokines, these two, so is this one, is a chemokine slash cytokine.
This is a growth factor intermediate.
So, why would a cancer clinic run these tests?
Well, so you're looking, these are inflammatory cytokines.
There's also anti-inflammatory cytokines.
So, these IL-1, IL-6, and IL-8 are part of the TH-1 immune system.
So, your immune system could be separated through a couple different classifications.
So, as far as how your immune system affects the rest of your body as far as inflammation goes,
there's the inflammatory immune response, which is the T-helper-1 response.
Now, that's mainly part of your initial immune response.
So, if you have an infection, you have inflammation at that side of the infection,
because it's bringing in these initial responders, our chemokines and cytokines,
that will initiate that response to draw lymphocyte family into the area to kill possible infections.
So, you slice your arm open with a knife, and it becomes infected and ran there so that it's causing this immune response
to draw lymphocytes and macrophages to the area to kill the infection.
That's how you prevent dying from a blood infection with an injury.
But, you get an elevation of these cytokines for other inflammatory events.
That's why I'm very big on getting food sensitivity testing and chemical sensitivity testing and things like that,
because if you're exposed to enormous amount of toxic chemicals, you're going to have an inflammatory event.
If you're exposed to foods that you have antibodies against, that's going to cause an inflammatory event.
So, that's not good when you got this systemic inflammation.
So, these are part of the TH1 cascade. There's other ones too that are not listed here.
But, these are inflammatory cytokines. They could do damage long-term by blocking one's ability to kill cancer cells.
So, one of the things that builds up on the outside of a growing cancer is this one, interleukin-6.
So, interleukin-6 is inflammatory, and it can be a waste product from rapidly replicating cells.
So, getting rid of this would be a good thing. That's why you take curcumin. That's why you take green TEG-CG.
And it's resveratrol. And the flavonoids that decrease inflammation, you're trying to decrease inflammation in other things that you're eating, you're trying to...
What are the reasons you're talking to somebody about their labs the other day?
And they had a lot of different toxicities. And the idea is that we're trying to clean up our physical environments,
not so that we could not be exposed to any toxins, but that any time you can lower your dosage of toxicity, you're going to decrease the overall inflammatory process in your body,
and you're going to be able to use your immune cells to kill other things like infections and cancers instead of dealing with chemicals and food sensitivities and other reasons why we are becoming inflated.
And it even gets worse if you have antibodies to self-tissue, aka an autoimmune disease because every time you are exposed to some trigger that causes inflammation, you're going to also kill your healthy cells and your tissues as well.
As far as seruloplasm, seruloplasm is one of the things that we look at the genes that we look at when we look at your genetics because if you have a lot of defects with that, it's really easy to get a build-up of copper and what's called a copper toxicity.
And a copper toxicity is actually quite common. People think they need to be taking copper, I see videos on Instagram about using copper bracelets and using copper pans because copper is so good for you.
Those people do not know what they're talking about. You're exposed to a lot of copper. If you eat a decent diet, you're getting more copper than what you need in order for your cells to survive.
And hopefully your body is doing a good job of getting rid of excess copper. But some people with genetic issues don't do that very well.
And they end up with a copper toxicity which causes a whole slurry of cascade of issues that a person could have.
And don't know that I've never tested anybody and it'd be the cause of cancer. But one of the things that have it excess copper does is it decreases your zinc.
So copper and zinc go together in your tissues and you can measure a copper zinc ratio in your blood to get an idea. Though it's not perfect, you get an idea of where that person's at with copper.
So I don't want my cancer patients taking supplements with copper in them.
We don't want excess copper. Copper is a growth factor piece and excess copper causes, you know, inability to detoxify other things.
And it pushes out zinc and zinc is necessary for the immune response and it's necessary to help kill cancer.
So veg F is different vascular endothelial growth factor can be measured with a blood test as well.
And why would you measure that? Because excess veg F is not good for cancer.
Well, it's indifferent for blood cancers like leukemia or multiple myeloma, but it is not good for any solid cancer.
So if you have an increase in vascular endothelial growth factor, you have an increase in growth of blood vessels, which is actually what you would want to do.
You'd want to do things that would increase veg F. You'd want to take supplements that would increase veg F.
If you did not have cancer and you had heart issues, heart disease, you know, early heart disease, heart disease in your family.
You'd want to do things that increase veg F, which would be like taking nitric oxide supplements, you know, doing, you know, a lot of exercising, aerobic type exercising is going to increase veg F.
Doing long fasts like more than a couple of day fast is going to increase veg F.
It's also going to increase IGF one, which is another growth factor.
So if you don't have cancer, it's good to increase IGF one.
It's good to increase veg F. But if you do have cancer, you don't want to do things to increase veg F and IGF one.
Because you'll increase the growth of blood vessels in the tumor, thereby, you know, allowing food sources to get in the tumor.
So the tumor is growing from the center out and it's growing, those are rapidly growing tumors.
So you want to do things that decrease veg F that decrease IGF one, that decrease copper levels.
So, but okay, so then you go, whoa, good, I should run these labs. Dr. Cutters, why don't you have everybody run these labs?
I don't see that in your choices for labs to run.
And the reason is is that, okay, so we already, we are all know that we have inflammation at different sites.
You're not always going to have an elevated inflammatory markers in the blood as far as cytokines.
Cytokines are going to be processed quite quickly through the liver. They're not going to stay in the blood.
They're going to stay in the tissues and cause inflammation of the tissues.
We already know that's there. We don't need to measure that.
So I don't see any need to measure cytokines in the blood.
And the reason why those tests exist is that if you think this person has an acute poison either something,
they're rushed to the hospital with an ER. We don't know what's wrong with them. They're super sick.
They don't have a fever. We run a CBC. They don't have any elevated CBC blood markers.
What is going on? You could run cytokine tests to see if they have some acute inflammatory response to something like they were poisoned with arsenic.
As far as using them from a functional medicine perspective to say this person has inflammation,
I don't really see a value in that because the truth is from a metabolism standpoint, cytokines are processed quickly through the liver.
And guess what the byproduct of processed cytokines in the liver is? It's what was called in what we call c-reactive protein.
So if a person has chronic inflammation that is being processed well,
they will have an elevated c-reactive protein or another test is what's called high sensitivity c-reactive protein.
You used to be called cardiac c-reactive protein, but c-reactive protein in general is the sign of inflammation.
It doesn't say where. We don't know where it is. We don't know what it's from, but there's inflammation that's present.
But it goes deeper than that. Remember every blood test is a clue. It's a hint.
It's pointing a flashlight at something for you to look a little deeper into something.
A person could have a whole bunch of other signs of inflammation of their body and not have elevated c-reactive protein.
So there's other things that you can look for as their fairytale level increases.
Their send rate changed is there, you know, there's other things that you're looking for.
And certainly you're not just looking at the objective blood test. There's other objective findings and subjective findings that would point you towards that differential diagnosis.
So I don't run these tests. Well, why don't you run Vegef or IGF1? There's a way to run them because you can't really, you know, you can't really change them.
The only time you'd maybe run this test is that the person is doing, you know, you know, has heart serious heart disease at the same time they're dealing with cancer.
So they're taking nitric oxide for their heart disease and you want to make sure that it's not causing progression of the cancer.
So you may run those tests for those reasons. But as far as what you're going to be able to do to change these numbers, it's not, to me, it's not a value to spend the money on these tests.
I mean, we could, you know, if we had endless pockets, we could run a zillion different labs.
But, you know, I'd rather have a person spend their money in the correction of their overall health and doing the things we know we should do anyhow.
And like the question before, maybe he spent the money on getting a PDF for spend the money on getting a localized hyperthermia or a sauna or something like that, then running these labs because you still have to do that, do the work to, you know, to, to move your body into reinstated holostasis anyhow.
So why don't we just do that work.
These get to be expensive. So that is the main reason why I don't run this.